欢迎收看独大的信尚课程
今天跟你分享的是海归交易法则
赚上益的一个方法
那么今天会把这个方法来去做一个实战的改良
这个方法就是弹行情通道
再加上CCI指标的一个实战的操作
我们看一下这是最近几天开始期的行情的一个涨跌
最近三天的行情
我们可以看到这个行情的波动很大
例如说这个低点32782
涨到这个34030
这波上涨涨多少点
涨1248点
就一天的时间
然后回档也是回档了1400点
反弹600点
再次的回档又下跌了986点
所以最近的这个行情的反弹震荡
都很容易超过1000点的一个涨跌幅
所以最近的平均的波动
是非常非常巨大的
然后在这么大的一个巨大的行情里面
我们怎么抓到行情的方向
跟怎么样抓到行情的转折
例如说我们看一下这个是通道
这个是今天想跟大家介绍的主角
叫做唐奇洋通道
这个通道我们可以看到
在这三个镜头的位置
在这个相对的高档
然后在这两个位置
在相对的低档
我们有没有办法再搭配这个CCI指标
来去抓到行情的相对高低档的位置
这是今天想跟大家分享的主题
什么主题
就是第一个
我们可以利用通道来判断方向
利用CCI来去抓行情的可能转折点
再来最后一个最重要的就是
我们可以利用这个海规交易法则
帮助我们在市场上面来去做交易
今天分享这三个重点都很重要
尤其是第三个重点
你一定要听到最后
大家好
我在读到我是专职的交易人
如果你也是在交易股价期货选择的话
请你订阅我的频道
我的频道是专门讲解投资底彩的频道
你可以订阅起来
慢慢的来去做收看
我们先来看一下这个通道怎么化
那今天要交的通道是禅奇样通道
我们先看一下上通道
上通道的公式
它就是过去N跟K棒的最高价
把它给画出来
例如说这个N跟K棒是10跟K棒
或是50跟K棒
过去一段时间的
这个趋近K棒的最高价
把它给画出来
这个叫上通道
第二个叫做下通道
下通道的画法就是
过去N跟K棒的最低价
把它给画出来
再来一个中通道
中通道的画法就是
这个中间这个虚线的这个位置
它就是上通道加上下通道
然后加起来除以2
这个就是中通道的画法
所以这个弹琴亚通道怎么画
它就是过去一段时间的
KM的高点跟低点
然后跟它的一个平均值
把它给画出来
这是弹琴亚的画法
那接下来我看一下
这个通道怎么用
首先是下降通道
什么叫下降通道
就是它这个上通道
中通道跟下通道
三个通道同步往下走
这个叫做空框走势
所以我画镜头这个位置
上中下通道頭部往下走
你可以看到這個接地線頭部往下
這個接地線頭部往下
然後這個KBON大部分時候
是在中通道的下方
像我這個滑鼠光碟這個地方
KBON大部分都是在中通道下方
這個往下跌
這個叫做空方走勢
所以通道的用法
第一個是先判斷
這個行情它是不是在下通道
像這裡也是一樣
這一段的這個通道
上中下通道通通往下跌
通通往下走
而且这个价格大部分时候
都是在中通道的下方
这个叫做通风走势
那如果是上升通道的话
画的红色线的这一段
这一段怎么样
它的上通道中通道下通道
它都是往上爬的
这个叫做上升通道
那上升通道的话
它是多方走势
那这一段的走势呢
KBUN大部分时候
都是在中通道的上方
往上前进
这个叫多方走势
所以我们去做交易的时候
我们可以利用通道
来帮助我们判断它是怎么样
它是价格正在往上走
或者是价格正在往下跌
其实这个还蛮视觉化的方式
可以看得出来
那第三个的话就是通道变载
而且横盘的话代表是盘整
例如说这个蓝色镜头这段
这段这个通道它都是变载
而且K半是横盘的
所以最后是盘整
那如果通道变宽的话
可能暗示着行情的发动
例如说这个黄色圈圈这块
这块的话
这个通道上下很明显变宽了
对不对
就是碰碰变大了
行情发动
然后后面行情是怎么样
点一大段下去
就代表是有趋势的发动
这个就是我们通道的用法
接下来跟大家讲一个故事
在1983年的时候
期货市场上面
有两位传奇的交易员
一位是Richard Dennis
一位是他的好朋友
那这个Dennis就跟他的好朋友
去做一个争辩
争辩说什么
这个会赚钱的交易员是天生的
还是可以透过后天的训练的
那Dennis他认为说
这个会赚钱交易员
是可以透过训练出来的
就像是新加坡的海哥养殖场一样
只要给正确的命令
给正确的方法
然后平凡人也可以变成交易的高手会赚钱
那他的好朋友
艾克拉特他认为是交易是他需要添付的
他是在灵魂里面的东西
他是交不出来的
于是他们来说打赌
然后为了打赌呢
这个Dennis他在华尔街日报里面
他刊登广告招募学员
因为他那个时候他已经很出名了
他在市场上面赚很多钱
所以招募学员可以
免费的来去做训练
所以有非常多一般的人
就是投理率去应征
想要成为教育的高手
然后有上千名的应征者
他是从里面挑出13个人
后来增加到21个人
这群人的背景各异
有的是司机
有的是桥牌的玩家
有的是大学生
有的是老师
这群人他的行业都不一定
都不一样
可是透过一个教育的方式
可以把这些本来都不会交易的人
变成会交易的一些会赚钱的高手
所以赌局非常非常的有名
因为他最后成功了
这群被训练出来的海归们
他训练出来大概是两个月时间
并没有很长
训练出来以后
帮他这个老师
帮这个Dennis来去做交易
在四年半的时间
平均年化报酬率高涨80%
然后帮他老师赚了一亿的美金
这个实验非常成功
其中一个学院
Curtis Fesh
他当年只有19岁
然后用这套方法赚了3000万的美金
然后他还写了一本书叫做海归交易法则分享他这群学院们怎么在市场里面赚到大钱所以可以看得出来这套方法的确实是可以复制的
那这套方法非常核心的命运武器
就是什么
就是今天所分享的弹琴样空道
这个海归们
就是利用这个弹琴样通道
来去抓行情的可能的一个突破的进场点
因为这个海归们
他们都是用一个趋势的方法来去做交易
去追随趋势
怎么追随呢
就是行情突破区间
对不对
突破区间就是趋势发动
所以它的方法非常有效
是怎么做呢
第一步就是要去找区间的突破
它利用的方法是
找过去20日的区间的突破
不管是突破的高点
或者是突破的低点
它来去做一个顺势的交易
那第二个进场点
就是抓更大的区间
例如说突破55日的一个区间的高点
或者是区间低点
这个行情的突破
这是第一个突破的一个条件
然后第三个非常重要的就是加码机制
它加码机制是每走一段来去做个加码
例如说走个N
它这个N就等于ATR
也就是这个行情平均的波动
每走一个平均的波动
它就加码一次
走两个平均的波动
走两个N的话它就加码两次
然后这个N它也当做它的一个停损的条件
它进场它的停损就是一个N
这是它的加码机制
这个加码机制在海归获利商议法则里面
它是屬於靈魂的機制
就是你要加碼
才會顯現出這個方法的威力
你不加碼的話
這個方法的威力就會大幅的打折
所以這個方法裡面
這個海歸交易法則裡面
有個非常核心的邏輯
就是靠加碼來去放大貨利用
然後最後一個就是出場
它出場條件是
當這個行情走反向
跌破10日的這個通道的話
這個怎麼樣
它就來去做一個出場
这个是海归获利法则的
这几个重要的步骤
他说靠这套系统训练他的学院
操作不同的一个商品
然后可以达成惊人的效果
平均年化报酬率80%
然后为Denis赚进1亿的美金
那这套系统爆猴以后出现一个现象
是什么现象
就是当大家都知道你怎么赚钱的话
你这个赚钱的方法可能
就会开始失效
或者是开始被修理
也就是说在早期
他这个方法在什么时候
在1980年的時候
它那個時候突破效果是非常非常好的
可是當大家都知道
你這樣子做的以後
這會發生什麼事情
可能就會發生越來越多的腳的突破
或者是這個行情走勢會變得比較短
沒有像以前一樣可以一個突破大的波段
所以我們在現在這個時候
這個方法我們要來去做個改良
怎麼改良呢
第一個就是進場不見得要用突破
他早期是用突破進場
可是現在不見得要突破進場
你反而可以考慮用假突破進場
也是非常不錯的
或是拉回進場
所以今天我要教你
就是把海瑰交易系統來去做個改良
可是出場我覺得還是可以用
出場是可以用
就是當這個K棒跌破
反向的跟K棒高低點的時候
來去做出場
這個是核心
這剛好也是我交易的核心
也是WINSMART設計的核心
就是你進場
你可以用各式各樣的方式進場
你可以突破進
拉回進
然後假突破進
可是出廠我們都是用同套的東西來去做出廠
這個就是在現在可以適應現在的行情的一個較為的方式
也就是海貴系統改良
接下來我們講一下CCI指標的用法
CCI指標它是用來抓一個超漲超跌的一個技術指標
它判斷說這個CCI指標它的數據
這個底下這個指標叫CCI
當它計算出來的數值大於這100以上的話
代表說行情差是非常強的
它會走出一個趨勢
那小于-100的话就是偏做
他可能会走出一个空头
那在正100跟-100中间
他代表说行情在一个正常的值
它是一个震荡区间
那反之呢
那如果这个CCI指标
他突破了正100
然后呢
再跌破正100的话
代表说行情由盛转衰
跌破-100再突破-100的话
就是由弱转强
例如说我们这个左边这个图
这个地方
我画两个黄色空旺的位置
在最底下这个叫做-100
跌破-100
然后又突破-100的位置
对应到上面的KBOB
这个就是行情游肉转强的点
OK
这个就是用CCI来去抓行情的
相对的高低点反转点的一个用法
就是专门去抓这个行情的
这个突破-100的位置
跟这个跌破-100的位置
来去抓行情的一个反转点
那我们今天把这个CCI指标跟通道
结合在一起
那如果这个CCI指标
它出现转折点在通道附近的话
可以增加它的准确度
因为我们可以看到这个弹起压通道
这个上通道可以把它当做是一个压力
下通道可以把它当做是一个支撑
那如果我们CCI指标
它发生这个转折的位置
它刚好发生在这个通道的附近
例如说我们可以看到这个黄色圈圈的位置
它发生在通道上通道的附近
然后出现这个CCI出现转折的话
那么可能是可以控在航行的高点
这个位置也是一样
这个CCI出现突破100
再跌破100
对应到上面的K线
刚好也在通道
上通道的附近的话
它就是行情的转折点
介绍一下突破跟假突破
这个就是顺势交易者的一个痛
这是非常头大的地方
因为顺势交易
这是趋势突破就是顺势
像海贵交易
它也是专门做突破的
突破以后去抓一个趋势出去
可是也会出现很多的假突破
所以在这个地方
我们就要看得懂
突破跟假突破
这是你要去做交易
不管是股票也好 日期货也好
这是个非常重要的交易技巧
什么叫突破
就是突破区间的高点
例如说这个K棒往上突破
这个区间K棒的高点
行情一路往上涨
这是一个成功的案例
那失败案例是什么
突破区间高点以后
然后又掉下来
这个叫失败的案例
所以现在比60几年前
更多这个失败的案例
所以你一定要看得懂
什么是真的突破
什么是假的突破
那如果你问我说
突大突大
我怎么知道
突破当下它是真的还是假的
我可以很誠實告訴你
不知道 事後你就知道
所以我的做法是怎麼樣
我的做法是
如果他是真突破的話
我們就做趨勢
如果他是假突破的話我們就做反向這樣可以嗎分大航金不是往上走是往下跌所以我的做法就是修正他是正式突破話 我們就做反向這樣可以嗎分道行情不是往上走 是往下跌所以我的做法就是修正他是正式突破的話我們就一路往上做
他是反向突破的話
至少我們可以做反向空
還有機會這段下跌
還可以撞得到錢
所以假突破他有四個步驟
第一個步驟就是突破區間
突破區間我們看一下這個圖形
上面往上突破區間
他就是一個突破
可是突破區間以後又馬上拉回
奇怪 突破區間
他應該往上幹嘛拉回呢
那他第二個是怎麼樣
他第二個是這個CCI的超漲跟超點的拉回
看一下他底下指標
底下指標他突破區間以後
CCI指標他突破100
突破100標非常高以後
他又拉回跌破100
他是第二個行情走假突破的一個特徵
就是CCI指標衝動很強
然後又轉弱
那第三個特徵是什麼東西
就是拉回跌破中軌走反向
在这个位置
突破上轨以后
它居然会跌破中轨
那就是很奇怪
你突破上轨
它应该持续往上走
可是它却拉回跌破中轨
那就是行情走落
后面行情是走反向
走反向以后
这个通道开始走下降通道
又是另外一个趋势
太棒了
所以我们去做交易的话
你可以这样用
突破不成怎么样
反手来去看空
它也是会走一大段
所以现代化的
凯规改良的交易系统
怎么做呢
第一个步骤
先从风险控制开始
这个风险是非常非常重要的
我们停损根据ATR来去做设定
台北的停损是设一倍的ATR
当一倍ATR发生的时候
损失本金的1%
台子期最近的一倍ATR
你知道是多少吗
是1000多点是1200点
一倍的ATR就是一天的平均波动的大小
所以最近平均波动大小是1200点
你可以有办法设定你停损是1200点吗
然后只是损失本金的1%
哇这个很难嘛对不对
因为你要很大很大的资金
才能够设1200点停损
而且只损失资金的1%
这个大资金才能做
那一般人不可能设定这么大的停损
所以我们怎么做
我自己的做法是
我会设定每天平均波动的20%到25%
来当做我的参考的停损
然后当这个损失发生的时候
是本金2%
这是我的做法
也是可以比较适合大多数的投资人可以做到
把这个停损拉小一点
可是损失百分比还是建议损失在5%以内
这是非常重要的
就是你会看错
你要可以接受连续错误这件事情
所以当币损失要剩的比较小
然后第二个就是进场
那进场的方式
海归的方式他专门做突破
他专门抓大的趋势
那现在呢
我觉得你可以抓突破
你可以抓假突破
或者拉回进场都可以
第三个就是出场
第三个的方法我们就没有改变它
就是价格反向跌破
这个恩根开放高低点的时候
我们来去做出场
第四个的话就是加码
海贵的加码方式是
它的天然是一倍ATR
它走一倍ATR的时候来去做加码
OK
那我们现在我们走一倍ATR
再去做加码看办
比如说行情走了1200点
再去做加码
天哪
有点太远了吧
我们是做比较短一点
我把这个节奏变得比较短一点
我们可以当这个行情
走了一倍的停损
或者是一点差倍的停损的时候
你来去做加码
例如说你的停损上20%
那你可以走这个20%的时候
来去做加码
或者是你可以走这个30%的ATR的时候
这样知道为什么吗
就是你加码的间距可以大于等于
这个停损的距离
你来去做加码
所以我们现在的做法是怎么样
是一个缩小版的海规系统
我们改良了什么
改良他的进场点
然后把停损设置比较小
然后停地的逻辑我们照用
加码的速度更快
这是我们现代版的海归的改良系统
然后我们可以利用这个通道
再加上CCI来提高我们进场交易的胜算
我们做一个示意图
示意图就是这边
我们可以利用这个通道
再加上CCI来去找一个
相对胜算比较高的一个进场点
进场以后
我们第一个动作是先设定停损
先设定停损
这个停损
损失的资金可以亏损的钱
是你本金的5%以内
最好是2%以内
然后接下来一个动作非常重要
是你要移动停地
移动停地
这个黄色的线都是移动停地的轨迹
直到这个价格
反转打到你的移动停地线的时候
来去做出场
这个移动停地线是我们刚刚说的
突破N跟K帮的高低点的时候
来去做一个出场
所以这个黄色的线就是
确定K帮高低点的概念
只要突破的话就来去做一个出场
然后中间我们再去打加码
中间去打加码加码
然后到你停地线的时候来去做出场
这个是现代版的海归的交易系统
那接下来
JongWinSmart示范研究给你看
现在用WinSmart来去做交易
因为最近波动比较大
所以我把大台改成小台
我们来做一下
我们来看一下这个地方
首先设定一下停损停地
那停损的话
我设定220TIC来当作为了停损
为什么呢
因为这个如果是20%的ATR
大概是247点
对不对
所以你220点是接近20%
这是那个概念
这是根据ATR来去计算说
你的停车点数是多少
OK
我这边是打220
因为看一下这边的
14天的平均ATR是1233点
所以这个行情波动很大
平均每天波动只有1200多点
我们再看一下这个
这个移动体力的设定在这边
这是一通天地的设定
然后再去勾选一下加码的条件
示范给你们看
我们现在开始来去做交易
我们在这个地方看到
这个轨道它来去做一个收链
它这个底部的轨道
它渐渐往上走
上面轨道它也往下
代表说行间在一个区间横盘之地
在这个地方我们可以看到
底下这里吸气爱指标
吸气爱指标
它出现这个迫100
然后再突破100
就是这个CCI指标的超跌之后的回弹
所以这个地方是短线转强点
如果看盘整区间的话
然后又出现这个底部的通道它是不是有渐渐往上它渐渐往上代表说这个KBUN它的形态是渐渐向上的所以这里我想试着去做多我进场以后我立刻设停损
停损就是设定我刚刚说的
大约是20%的ATR在当做停损
接下来它就开始移动停地跟加码
你可以看到这边它甚至帮我加码
我进场以后设停损
220点停损
然后后面行情涨一段
再涨220点我再去做加码
这是我的一个停损的条件
跟加码条件
OK
然后也来去做个移动停地
蓝色的线就是我的移动停地
然后我现在因为是做短线
所以我加码只加一次
这样生存比较高
现场是停损
移动停地跟加码
后面就报注获利
这个行情拉回
跌破我们刚刚说的条件
就是蓝色的移动停地线
就去天开放高点
去天开放高低点
跌破去天开放高低点的时候
我来去做停地
没有打到的话就续报
所以我现在还正在往上报
我们可以看到这个地方
它走出这个通道
它是走出什么
上升通道
通道的上缘
渐渐的往上爬
通道的下缘
也是渐渐的往上爬
这个是属于一个上升通道
OK
那它现在没有打到我的停地
我就抱着
没有打到停地就抱着
直到最后这个价格
拉回打到我的停地的时候
我才来去做一个出场
OK
好
那这个行情它还在走
所以我们进场以后就放着
这个Winsmart呢
它可以在你睡觉的时候帮你固盘
你进场到现在已经超过24个小时了
那你不可能人整天在看盘
所以你只好找给机器人帮你来做做看盘
它继续往上走
我们继续保住部位
它回档的话我们就获利
回档的话我们就获利
OK那现在这个行情
它拉回了
最后出场我们赚了10万块
我们做了两口小台赚了10万块
也不错
最近波动很大
建议投资人降低杠杆
所以我们从这边到这边
抱了一波获利
做两口小才赚了10万块
我们刚刚做多的
我们再做一趟
这个地方好像往上突破
照理说是偏多看嘛
对不对
往上突破算是偏多嘛
可是他马上又掉回来
这个地方就是一个讯号
突破区间开放高点又掉回来
再加上底下的CCI指标
它突破100又跌破100
这个是CCI指标的转租点
我们刚刚说讲突破四个步骤
突破区间高点
然后CCI指标也是突破100
然后又掉回100
这完成第二个步骤
然后再完成第三个步骤
就是它跌破中轨
突破上轨又跌破中轨
这太奇怪了
突破干嘛掉下来
所以这个地方就代表说
航前可能转弱了
我们进场来就说放空
OK 进场以后立刻是停损
然后走一段停损距离
帮我来自作加买
这个地方是假突破
所以我们用海贵交易法则
我们不见得要去做突破交易
我们可以来去做假突破交易也是可以的
就是我们改良一下进场点
你可以突破交易
可以假突破交易
也可以反弹空
或是拉回买都可以
像这个地方就反弹空的点
因为如果你在一开始没空的话
这个地方航行往下
这边就反弹空
所以你可以从这边开始进场
然后一样进场开始是停水
反正不管在哪边进场
后面的逻辑都是一样的
都是一樣的
好我們現在就是
開著這個軟體
讓mysmart幫助我來去多交易
我只要事先把一些停損停利條件都設定好
然後接下來他就可以幫助我來去做單
OK
他就可以幫助我來去做單
我進場立刻設停損
然後我現在是加碼一口
我現在來去做空
那這個行情他正在走下降通道
上中下三個通道
這個指同步往下化
就是同步往下
所以我们就是这段行情就走空嘛
很明显的刚刚是做个假突破
然后来做个反转
所以我们在这个地方来去做
假突破的反转来去做空
空方行情是跌断
然后什么时候出场呢
价格反弹到
到达我这个停地条件的时候
我来去做出场
这是我的停地条件
OK
那你就可以放着给他跑
这个地方行情刷一下
少到我们停地条件我们出场
这笔交易我们结束了
好这一波行情下跌
做空两口小台赚了66400块
也不错
我们赚到什么
我们赚到时间
就是不用熬夜盯盘的时间
我们在白天进场
白天这个9点
4点的时候进场
后面到了晚上9点的时候出场
就是这一整段时间
不用整天在看盘
你可以去上班
可以去工作
你可以去游乐
你可以去睡觉
然后呢
城市他每分每秒帮我盯住我的K棒
什么时候该停损
什么都在停地
现在是AI的时代
你还在用人工在盯盘吗
我们当然希望AI把这个条件
设给机器人设给电脑
让程式帮助我来去做运作
我觉得这样是比较省事
比较省力 比较聪明的
那这个WinSmart的发明呢
就是希望可以让我们做交易
做的比较简易 比较轻松
那我现在用WinSmart
帮助我帮助投资人来去做交易
我们可以把这个改良的
海规交易法则
把它设定起来 储存起来
方便我们下次来去做套用
下次你只要透用
刚刚设定的策略就可以
所以这个WinSmart可以设计
非常多种交易策略
那如果你想要学习
更多种的一个交易的方法
那如果想要更
进一步的了解我们的WinSmart的话
你可以来参加
WinSmart的线上讲座
每个月都会有一场
那4月份的讲座在4月底
在礼拜三礼拜四
在两天的晚上
报名的网址在影片的下方
有兴趣的朋友可以报名参加
我们的WinSmart呢
可以帮助你来去交易股票
期货选人权都可以哦
那如果想要学习更多的方法
想要更多了解WiSmart的话
来参加我们的WiSmart线上讲座
可以加入我们Lite
因为我们Lite有非常多的一些免费的资讯
有台股的资讯啊
充满资讯啊
又一些课程的教学啊
又一些非常多的文章啊
所以如果你对期货股
他选人权有兴趣的话
可以加入我们Lite
好的
那我们现在分享就到这边
感谢收看
想要简报同学
可以加入我们Lite
输入关键字可以得到这些简报
请不吝点赞 订阅 转发 打赏支持明镜与点点栏目